[Musique]
ce matin à 7 heures un champignon comme
celui ci a marqué en plein coeur du
sahara l'accession de la france à la
puissance atomique
cela s'est passé au centre d'essais de
reggane à quelque 200 km au sud d'alger
et à mille kilomètres au sud
est-ce de casablanca c'est là 211e
expérimentation du genre la première
ayant eu lieu le 16 juillet 1945 alamo
bordeaux aux états unis moins d'un mois
avant la destruction d'hiroshima et de
nagasaki qui mit fin à la guerre contre
le japon
[Musique]
l'union soviétique à son tour réussi sa
première explosion le 14 juillet 1949 et
puis ce furent les britanniques qui le 3
octobre 1952 expérimentèrent l'arme
atomique dans les îles montebello au
large de l'australie après ce fut la
bombe à hydrogène
là encore les américains furent les
premiers à l'utiliser
le 1er novembre 1952 les soviétiques les
imitèrent quelques mois plus tard et les
britanniques dur d'attendre près de
quatre ans avant de pouvoir utiliser à
leur tour la bombe h
[Musique]
ils luttent au total 210 expérience de
ce genre 134 américaine 55 soviétique
vingt-et-une britannique l'organisation
des nations-unies ne s'en émeut guère
elle ne commença en fait à s'inquiéter
que lorsque la france fit connaître son
intention de suivre le chemin des trois
autres grands l'assemblée générale de
novembre dernier condamne à les projets
français malgré les assurances données
par notre délégué monsieur lumière
[Musique]
pourquoi nous demandons préparer cette
explosion au sahara plutôt que dans une
île lointaine du pacifique
ce pourrait à me borner à répondre que
si le gouvernement français avec il y a
déjà plusieurs années retenu la seconde
solution au lieu de la première
l'argument nous eût été retourné par
d'autres états mais des raisons
techniques commandait sa décision le
sahara se prêtent mieux que toute autre
région à cette expérimentation past le
site choisi j'entends encore une fois le
polygone de sécurité délimité sur ses
150 km parce que le site choisi est à la
fois désert est beaucoup plus proche
d'eux les atolls des antipodes de la
france il s'y prête mieux
que le nevada et le kazakhstan je
voulais montrer les habitants de los
angeles ou de san francisco d'omsk ou de
nouveaux signaux étaient plus exposés
sans pourtant rien risquer que ne le
seront ce dock une ville marocaine
les populations de tous les états
voisins du sahara maroc tunisie libye
soudan ethiopie ghana liberia guinée
états de la communauté cours au moins de
danger que les habitants de la
californie et de la sibérie qui n'ont
couru aucun lors d'expériences le nombre
malgré l'onu les préparatifs étaient
activement poursuivi un régal
quelques 5000 technicien soit la
population de rambouillet ont poursuivi
leur tâche malgré le handicap du climat
52 degrés à l'ombre
au mois de juillet cinq cent mille
mètres cubes de terrassement une
casemate de 3000 mètres cubes 500 km de
routes 20 km de pistes ont été aménagés
en deux ans par 12 compagnie du génie
qui ont utilisé pour ce faire 200
véhicules automobiles et 60 gros engins
de terrassement pour faire jaillir de
terre
ce centre d'essai le plutonium utilisé à
reggane vient naturellement de l'usiné
de marcoule dont les trois piles
produiront bientôt une centaine de kilos
de plutonium par et tout ceci a abouti à
l'explosion ce matin de la première
bombe atomique française qui a eu lieu
du haut de ce pilot
[Musique]